partie arrivent en tête dans cinq décis
départements de la région Centre seul
l'Indre-et-Loire échappe à la règle mais
le parti est en deuxième position et en
tête quand même dans un nombre important
de pouvoir cours celle de Touraine ou un
électeur sur deux à voter Front national
Amanda Breuer Rivera avec Marion bazark
Courcelles de Touraine 500 habitants ont
340 inscrits sur les listes électorales
un grand gagnant l'abstention Myriam
tire le bar sur la place du village elle
n'a pas voté au premier tour mais quand
il allait au second pour elle ses
voisins opté pour le Front national en
raison des attentats une décision qui
n'a surprend pas plus que ça c'est pas
nouveau de trois ans que c'est fun qui
passe donc j'étais passé surprise en
fait voilà c'est un peu dommage mais bon
c'est comme ça dans la cuisine son fils
ne sait pas non plus rendu aux urnes et
le raz-de-marée bleu marine dans le
village ne l'inquiète pas
ça changera rien que ça soit d'un côté
ou de l'autre ça change rien donc
on verra la plupart de nos
interlocuteurs semblent désabuser de la
politique je trouve qu'il y a pas
forcément de FN le machin de l'autre
parce que on sait plus qui croire petit
à croire qui est bon franchement si
j'aurais eu à voter je pense que
j'aurais fait aussi elle reste prudente
quant aux promesses du FN je pense que
il y a du bon comme il y a du moins bon
mais bon après avoir si ça si bien à
passer après avoir si ils vont ils vont
vraiment faire quelque chose mais bon
avec tout ce qu'on nous a promis et qui
a pas forcément été fait sentiment
d'insécurité antérieure aux attentats
marre du chômage et lassitude de la
politique les pousse à voter et FN mais
Annie contrairement à Sandrine est une
convaincue de Marine Le Pen la vie elle
est quand même pas facile et s'il y a un
changement si elle passe ouais je pense
qu'il y aura sûrement du gros changement
Badia élu sans étiquette à la mairie
suggère une mesure radicale pour arrêter
l'effervescence autour de ce parti le FM
devrait monter au pouvoir ça nous
permettrait de voir que il serait pas
mieux que le Parti de Gauche qui serait
pas mieux que le parti de droite et que
il ferait autant que les autres ce
village est partagé entre désir de
changement et indifférence un électeur
sur 4 est allé voter pour l'extrême
droite et le double ne s'est pas rendu
aux urnes quand celles de Touraine n'est
pas un cas isolé le fait n'arrive aussi
en tête dans 1200 autres communes de la
région